this is conmigo an AI powered guide
designed to help all students learn when
subjects are giving them trouble con
can help
Kamika was fun and can transform
learning into an adventure kanmigo is
not just for students teachers can use
it too by toggling from student mode to
teacher mode then conmigo transforms
into the teaching assistant you've
always wanted select the activities
section to begin it's going to show you
all of the wonderful things that Khan
mego can do you can have a chat with
gonemigo conmigo can give you a class
snapshot of how your students are doing
it can summarize your students chat
history so you can see what they've been
up to
feeling iffy about an upcoming standard
that you're about to cover use conmigo
to refresh your knowledge and then use
it again to come up with a creative
lesson hook that gets your students
excited about your content and then use
it again to write unique
thought-provoking exit ticket questions
conmigo can create a Humanities lesson
plan and help you collaborate with your
students to create a fun class summary
poem
conmigo can help you write learning
objectives for an upcoming unit and help
you co-create a writing rubric for your
students next essay ready to seekonmiko
in action me too let's start with a
creative lesson hook
conmigo are you ready to get started
absolutely me too let's get going
it's been a while since I've taught
Romeo and Juliet so conmigo can you
please help me come up with a creative
lesson hook for act three of Romeo and
Juliet for my 9th grade English class
of course you can conmigo came up with
two fantastic hooks that I can use with
my students
hmm actually on second thought a lot of
my students think that Shakespeare is
boring conmigo can you give me a funny
hook that will help keep my students
engaged
since starting the class with a
Shakespearean insop that is hilarious
and my students will love it thanks
conmico
okay conmigo I'm going to need a quick
check for understanding to use with my
students to make sure that they
understand act three before moving on to
act four could you please help me create
an exit ticket for them
wow these are wonderful
thought-provoking questions it's really
going to show me whether or not my
students need more support with act 3 of
Romeo and Juliet thanks so much conmigo
I think Mr Shakespeare would approve
after reviewing my students exit tickets
I'm noticing that there are a few
students who still aren't quite grasping
the concepts in the play so who better
to help them than Mr William Shakespeare
himself excuse us Mr Shakespeare but
could you please help my class
understand why Friar Lawrence didn't
intervene with Romeo and Juliet
great explanation couldn't have said it
better myself
that was super helpful in just a few
minutes conmigo my new teaching
assistant just saved me hours of
planning Time by helping me create
quality lesson plans for my students and
conmigo isn't just for English kaniko
could also support teachers and students
with subjects such as Math Science
History a variety of foreign languages
with levels ranging from elementary
through college incorporating conmigo
into the classroom is going to be a game
changer for teachers
[Music]
those insights and suggestions are going
to enhance classroom learning and make
teachers lives Easier by saving them so
much time they'll have the ability to
focus on what's important their students
thank you conmigo
foreign
[Music]